even better quote Steve Jobs he said the
people that are crazy enough to believe
that they can change the world
are usually the ones actually forget
what's true and you have to say what
serves me better what's going to empower
me better and to say I'm just born how
I'm born and I'm good at what I'm good
at it takes me all the power yeah it's
much better to say you know what I can
be whatever I want to be I just need to
practice I don't believe listen you
cannot snooze I'm born this way there's
an excuse for anything you can do you
want to how do you want to be cuz you
have a choice listen I mean I'm not
judging anyone if you're happy how you
are been great but don't moan and say
it's because I was born that way no you
know what I don't if you've heard the
story of the guy two guys in fact you
grew up together
one guy was really successful really
rich really happy really nice happy
family loving husband the other guy was
a loser bum beat his wife no money I
mean to me these guys and I said to the
bad guy why are you such a bum why do
you beat your wife while you're now
Hollywood because my dad's that way
all right fine then they ask the other
guy why you so successful and happy and
and and you know rich and living I was
because my dad was a bum he beat my mom
I don't want to be that way same
situation same circumstances but they
both had a choice but generally speaking
I think that life is 90% what you make
it and Tempest and how you take it how
much that of that 10% do you think is
what you attract how do you mean but
it's a tempest it's not what happens to
you and 90% of it is how you react to
that no ok explain your life yeah your
life right now yeah your business
everything's happened to you who you are
this person is 90 percent how how you've
created that you've made that so what's
the 10 percent the 10 percent is how you
react to things biggest thing is having
putting time aside to have gratitude
I think being grateful is the biggest
asset yeah I'd agree with that if you're
an ungrateful person you even if you're
rich financially you have a good
business and stuff you just stink
entitled ungrateful proud arrogant and
there's a fine line between confidence
and arrogance and people sometimes I
think mission de stamina is arrogant but
I think arrogance and entitlement was
things do you think you should be more
humble mate should always be more humble
you can never be too humble and it's a
good thing those people think I'm the
boss no no I can't be seen cleaning
floors and stuff so it's not a good luck
it's against my brand it's a bad
positioning it's really not it's really
not it's good to value time but if
you're not prepared to do everything I
wouldn't do that principles believe me
then don't expect anyone else to do that
anyone that says something's not
possible is speaking from poverty of
poverty mindset because everything is
possible
you know like with it again within
reason you can take things out of
context but like I'm talking about what
it's not possible why not find solutions
for what is possible you know so anyone
the saying you can't do that that's not
possible that's risky that's that's for
me that's coming from a broke mindset
I'd rather hmm the way you're going
about doing that isn't gonna work it's
possible but let me show you the better
route that'll listen to but someone just
as you can't do it interested I've been
taught that all my life you know it's
like when people tell you that you can't
or even intended to do this but I DIF
know a lot of people say it's alright
for you you're happy now because you're
20 years old and you're single and
that's why you're so happy enough so
much energy wait until you're in a
relationship everything changes
and then you get in a relationship and
life still great and you still happy you
still got loads of energy wait five
years oh you ain't till your marriage
you wait and tell you how kids are you
wait to have a second kid you ain't
until the end it's like life life is
still fantastic actually
are you just prophesying your life on me
I think that's probably what this is
about
cuz you keep saying wait until wait
until wait until wait until but what's
next oh wait until they leave home then
you'll be depressed stop waiting for me
to be depressed stop waiting for me to
fail and you become successful stop
promise on your share of my life no
negativity no negativity and that's not
and people say you know I just you know
but you need to be a realist listen when
I need to be pessimistic I'm pessimistic
when I'm gonna doing a deal I look at
the worst case of the day that here's
the thing I'm addicted to success I'm
addicted to positivity and I'm
completely allergic to negativity some
people are allergic to money and they'll
sabotage it but I was on the opposite
everything's a sacrifice but it's always
worth it in the long way
[Music]